hello and welcome to the only podcast
voted to the Pro Bowl everybody else is
an alternate and we get the hundred
thousand dollar roster bonus whoa hey
Simms hey there hey Josh hey Adam good
to have you back Josh man feeling much
better I'd like to apologize to you
thank you I'd like to apologize to all
of the listeners who I got sick I know
that sometimes our podcast comes in loud
and clear and illness can be transmitted
through iTunes I think I was the only
one that actually got it
there was nothing our guy on Twitter
okay yeah guy on Twitter pro ball whoa I
am always simultaneously laughing at
people getting upset but then also
understanding why we get upset with
snobs right I believe the 30,000 foot
evaluation that you had was yet again
defensive lines different schemes
continues to screw people over right the
four three the three four we had this
argument every year around the draft
that's right Hugo there is not a
position that's actually called edge
right but we get situations where Chris
Jones who you believe other than Aaron
Donald is the best pass rushing
defensive tackle yeah he's being
classified as a defensive end right and
it's impossible for him to make the Pro
Bowl when he's undoubtedly one of the
best players in the other [ __ ] yeah
without a doubt it's an issue first of
all a lot of these guys have things in
their contracts that say if they go to
the Pro Bowl or right
sounds like the Chiefs sent him in as a
defensive end which also makes me think
did they do that deliberately knowing he
wouldn't so he doesn't hit any incentive
because if he would've laughs he's
getting it without without well he's got
like what 10 11 sacks he's got yes 12 no
one no one in the AFC at defensive
tackle has numbers like nobody's even
close to that as far as sad as a
defensive end yeah now you're up against
the d4 there's a lot of pjy
exactly right yeah Miles Garrett Melvin
Ingram right but as you always say in a
3-4 the defensive end you're a defensive
defensive tackle it's like you know
Richards see more effect like Richard
Seymour is his Pro Bowl nominations are
probably low too because he was listed
as a defense and then a three-four
defense for everybody out there the
tackle there's the nose tackle that's
right over the center but then the other
two tackles right even though they're
listed as d ends in a 3-4 they're still
TAC
like and they're gonna play head up on
the offensive tackle they're gonna play
head up and they're asked to do tackle
duties right hold the offensive tackle
up extend your arms and hold them in
place because we're gonna ask you to
disengage whatever way the ball carrier
goes we expect you to throw him away
right and then go do that the other
people mean sacs for Chris Jones holy
crap yeah and he's got a pick and also
every time they're in a big game he
plays out of his mind right Chargers
game all over Phillip Rivers Rams game
arguably one of the best defensive
players in the field yep
whether it was Donald or or anybody out
there every single game he comes up big
yeah the other people yeah we were
talked about before Andrew Luck should
have gotten over Tom Brady right
deshaun Watson could have gotten over
Tom Brady Yeah right Darius Leonard
should have been in there
Gary's Leonard should without doubt
being I mean over Bernard Rick McInnis
right and we and he had a reason to be
upset I saw a lot of people saying
Leighton van der s should have been in
but I don't know if he goes in over
Bobby Wagner or Luke Kuechly no or
Anthony bar no he does not know like
their that that's one that people love
to say he should have been in I just
don't see them no no no hey man it's
good it's been a great start to his
rookie year all those things he's not in
they're lovely and the other people that
had an issue was Christian McCaffrey or
camara right I would argue are you
taking out se Kwang's Iker Gurley yeah
because I don't think that those two are
better than anybody and I'd say that
Christian I would put Christian
McCaffrey forth and then camara v I
think I would agree with you there and
you know I'm sorry I'm just checking one
thing because it just dawned on me too
that like Akeem Hicks is in the Super
Bowl I mean in the Pro Bowl and he plays
in a 3-4 scheme and he's messy I'm there
on their roster he's listed as a DT so
that's how they got away with it even
though he sometimes plays though that
sandy absolutely deserve to be in yeah
he did I mean without a doubt the only
reason I care is because of the roster
mode right I saw like snacks Harrison
say something about like what about me
he tweeted and not about not with that
group I'm just sorry
and the in the NFC with Fletcher Cox and
Aaron Donald Hakeem Hicks
I mean snacks you're awesome you're one
of the best one door stuffers there are
but that three right there is special
this you know what this really is
ya know when we have like the wide
receiver debates and people get upset
about who's fourth and whose fifth right
this is the time when it really
yeah yeah right about who's for that
whose 5th sure it certainly does I mean
what was the other one there was really
screw the pro-bowl I don't like yeah the
pro-bowl is I mean half these guys will
cancel out of this game
nobody's gonna ever give a damn about
the pro ball anymore I hope that the
public realizes that you know you know
like the league's changed where the
money is great I would never have Pro
Bowl stars in my sack in my contract you
wouldn't have it in there no I can't
control it
I want statistic based markers but if I
can okay yeah yeah but it's real Eric oh
you know what we wanted to give you that
$500,000 but we'll give it to you if you
make the all-pro I don't want to rely on
media people to get me money
yeah but either way I'm not having it in
there I mean if it's a good fit you know
added money right exactly right are you
saying about the money but the those the
the pro-bowl lost its luster for one
reason because of money right I mean you
know it's hard let's just say like first
Stephon Gilmore for instance so let's
just say that okay I'm just taking any
famous name on the list that found given
it's hard for him to go out there in the
Pro Bowl and put it all on the line for
what fifty thousand dollars he's making
a million dollars a game right now so
he's not gonna ruin his next career year
and that money coming in for oh if we
win the Pro Bowl I get sixty thousand if
we lose I get thirty five thousand in my
dad's era that was a lot of it mattered
like it matters to like guys like James
Connor
sure Darrius legs a clear right the guys
that are making hundreds of thousands in
the year that makes a difference in
their life but the majority of the star
players you know you know whoever it is
JJ Watt is is making no difference in
his life at all he's probably gonna
donate it or throw it don't know what
the cash are no one more you know what's
gonna matter yeah ten years from now
when they're up for the Hall of Fame and
they go he was only a six-time Pro
Bowler I say it every year yeah it's a
meaningless stat in a meaningless game
that gets importance when we when it
matters most
yeah that's we talked to Champ Bailey
right check how many all pros champ
how many Pro Bowls yeah come on put it
on all pros definitely a little more
prestigious Pro Bowl there's so much I
sure teachers the other thing I was
gonna say I mean a last Pro Bowl thing
do you think you agree with
like I don't know if James Connor
deserves to be in the Pro Bowl I think
it's very James Connor feet in my book
James Connor in the Pro Bowl I could
have predicted when he was the number
one jersey sale before even playing a
game it's the same reason both pounces
are in the Pro Bowl because nobody knows
the names of other centers and those
guys were in the first round and we
remember them every year yeah I know
it's it's you know I know that's going
over James Connor
well I look at like guys like first of
all I could look at Lamar Miller and I
would probably say his year is more
impressive I would have taken James Caan
really yeah man I mean I just I found
his rear very underwhelming I know he
went through a stretch there where we
all wanted to say it was the greatest
running back in the history of the sport
you're under estimating the fantasy I
don't know I mean yeah I mean that's but
that's ridiculous that's wrong Jo
mix-ins better than James Connor so but
we're not talking about better Jo
mix-ins really only planted under these
last few games he's got a better years
right now I'm looking at he's having a
better years got more words he's
averaging yard more yards per carry
being healthy is part of the deal again
you know again I just it bothers me that
just because he's on Pittsburgh you know
oh you just get in okay it bothered me
Keenan Allen doesn't deserve to be in
over juju Smith Shuster I agree with
that
Keenan Allen's really good he's just a
catch guy though he needed in the same
level as a Judy Smith Schuster is what
he does on a weekly basis for a team and
gets things done when they're not served
up to him they go awesome play design
and we have six other receivers that are
wide open and you're in them open in the
middle of the field all right so one
other thing that we like to argue about
happen on Monday night which is the
Carolina Panthers New Orleans Saints
game we're picking the games after
that's by the way yeah yeah we're doing
the full slate of games and we're gonna
pick and then dispersed within the games
we're gonna be doing some of Simms us
film notebook and perfect cursive an
incredible gambling moment Saints are up
three driving down the line is six yeah
boy left go bet on the Panthers your
enemy Simms bet on the Saints and there
goes well who fumbled it was Lewis no
wasn't it wasn't Lewis Tommy Lee Lewis
you're right absolutely he says it like
with such vigor okay because you're
wrong you're an idiot because no one has
ever referred to Tommy Lee Lewis not as
Tommy Lee you're the only one that poked
the little get me gonna Tommy Lee just
change the subject here right
tab and you'll erase half the podcast
let's come and he dough fanned the ball
went out of the end zone and as that
happened one eye covered which was
incredible but also all of the staunch
media heads said that it was awful what
a bad call the punishment doesn't fit
the crime
and you've always said it's hallowed
ground the end zone and when the ball
goes in there it enters North Korea
exactly right it's North Korea I call it
the beast from sanh ladder that as soon
as the ball goes over it's not yours
anymore right you need to go over and
ask for it back and they don't have to
give it to you wait the penalty totally
fits the crime foresaw you've lost the
ball and their terror their objective is
to stop you to get into that territory
if your team walks into that territory
with the ball in their hand you get six
points but if you lose that ball into
their territory yeah
it's out of your jurisdiction it's no
longer yours that's they're not in Korea
it's a North Korean gonna ask for it
back you gotta ask you gotta ask Kim
jong-eun back and go sir may I have it
back anyhow I go for the 20 yard line
sorry people always go but if it fumbled
at the six-inch line it wouldn't be that
penalty and I go well you don't get
points if you go out in the six-inch
line you get points if you go and ones
that people want like what are they
saying on Twitter they want the ball
back I got her I've heard your best
friend Big Cat say the ball should go on
the thirty and it's now first and goal
from the thirty right I've heard other
people say my friend Danny Parkins our
radio show host in Chicago it should be
first and 10 from the 20 which i think
is crazy
so then if I'm wasting clock I'm just
gonna purposely fumble it out and give
it yeah you're not getting rewarded team
downs cuz they lost the ball in the
hallowed ground that 11 men are trying
to stop you during getting you lost it
in their area and you're gonna go hey
sorry that's that's that's ting sure you
guys here's the ball back and hey why
ready here's four more downs for you
yeah absolutely I mean that's insane I
get everybody get out of fantasy world
like what if it was what if it was
fourth and goal to 20 I don't like any
of it I like the way it is it's not
their ball by their area the defense is
defending it and you lost it in their
area sorry it's just I don't know the
it doesn't make sense is what about
football is fair look what about
football is honestly you deserve another
chance and there's nothing like the only
thing that was like that was when teams
would fail an onside kick and then get
another chin and we fixed that you don't
get another chance at that anymore oh
you and offside sorry that's it the
other teams ball same thing with this -
Jean starett or says if you kick it out
of the end zone it's the other teams
both the 20 right if you punted out of
the end zone it's the other team's ball
at the 20 25 yeah but same thing with
the fumble
yeah no I'm with you a hundred percent
and I know I hear the IFS - and all the
is yes oh if you follow if you fumble at
the 6 inch yard line it shouldn't be
penalized like that but if he fumbles in
the endzone it's a touchdown if if if I
go back to what my old high-school coach
in New Jersey said don't have to already
know what you're gonna say fine
you guys ready to pick some games yeah
let's do it all right I'm Sims as an yep
looking back to week 15 just why you're
annoyed you guys are annoying go ahead
ok week 15 Chris went seven eight and
one you lost
1450 Bleacher bucks mostly thanks to the
Los Angeles Rams who lost you 1200 as
well as the Kansas City Chiefs who lost
you 200 you are now sitting at negative
2,350 bleacher bucks on the season oh
damn it's hard to get in the positives
now left go much less interesting you
went nine six and one you made a hundred
bleacher bucks and you're at positive
360 on the season whoo so what's that
gap to the math brain uh - 350 - 360 I
don't do math in my head it's like plus
360 I know I'm saying if I'm negative to
350 mile - 3710 yes so I'm pretty much
screwed well until we get to the bet
this week it could happen Josh isn't
really excited about the bets this way
and then for the records I know you guys
don't care but you're both 109 109 and 5
that's tied with your records okay first
game of the week so we're perfectly 500
what was there what was guaranteed to
lose guaranteed to lose Chris you rent
four and one Eagles the Eagles got me
right pick the Eagles GTL let's go one
in three in the locks bringing you to
twenty five three to two
you suck wow you suck Tim your five gate
six seven games under yeah I need an you
suck I need like two perfect weeks it
could happen stop doing the no no it's
Negative Nancy now you got him he's here
sorry say you're handsome yep negative
Nancy's here no Sam's name is Wendy is
Wendy gonna be at our wildcard weekend I
don't know if I'm going to be there yet
so I don't know that we don't care about
you we just don't know Wendy well you're
not allowed in my house without me there
so all right first game of the weekend
that's you know it's did that just
happen I don't know yet but I might have
to I know that can we watch else can we
hang out Phil I'm gonna go ahead sure
have fun he might be working too you
guys could drink some protein shakes and
do some push-ups together is he still
drinking protein shake he's constantly
doing egg whites at like 6 but he's not
anymore he's he's always working out
tell him if I find out that your dad is
just doing like an excessive amount of
lunges on a regular basis he's still
working out I mean there's no just cuz
he's got neck problems and shoulder
problems he can't live without that
that's not possible
he will realistic his whole week to make
sure he gets workouts in like that well
no matter what what I got to be a CBS
now ok CBS moved back a few hours I have
a workout to do then I'll be there CBS
for him yeah way to maintain the body
right all right 4:30 Saturday afternoon
Washington visiting Tennessee Saturday
good spread in this game is Tennessee
minus 10 Chris okay I do think that the
Redskins defense can still be annoying
for a Titans offense um that you know as
we've said throughout the year can be
somewhat predictable in the pass game
right I also think that they can hang in
there in the run game too I will be
shocked if Derrick Henry runs for 180
yards he might get to a hundred
somewhere along there but really you
know at times when you've seen the
Redskins defense fall apart as of late I
mean it's not really their defense
falling apart it's their offense just
putting them in continuously bad spots
and they finally the dam breaks but I
mean come on let's be serious the games
at Tennessee I'm not gonna expect Josh
Johnson to win this football game the
Titans are still playing
something yeah um I just have a hard
time thinking that that [ __ ] offense
is going to be able to consistently move
the ball on the Titans throughout the
day and I do think the Titans will be
able to muster up enough offense whether
it be just the boundless attack of some
good passing and some good running from
here or there and I think that the
Titans win a ugly one like 20 to 6 Oh
something like that I'm betting $10 on
the Tennessee Titans you puny little
[ __ ] you cannot come in to fight area
this is forbidden I totally forgot that
the Titans voice is a thing so Titans
just lost Logan Ryan how big of a deal
is that it hurts for sure I mean it
hurts nothing right no it's about future
opponents it's about the next week after
that against the Colts or if they get to
the playoffs and having to deal with
some of those teams so first thing is
Washington I think just had one of their
super gutsy wins last week Yeah right
and I see at the end of the game Josh
Johnson yelling at the ground and
excitement yeah I go there's a lot of
release of emotions Washington thrilled
they get this win let's not forget their
entire offense against Jacksonville had
245 yards and they still let up a
hundred and seventy two rushing yards
now for net was not the guy but they
also got it from Cody Kessler they also
got it from TJ Yeldon 172s a lot and
Jacksonville is three and five at home
now they're going to Tennessee Tennessee
is not three and five at home they're
five and one and they're running back
has discovered a new edge I literally
just interviewed Dennis Kelly right and
he said oh dude the switch has gone off
yeah Derrick Henry had 170 against the
Giants 238 against Jacksonville that's
over 400 yards and two games the
question I would have for you is the
Washington run defense yeah you know I
it's not the way it was before no it's
not they lack a little depth at time so
they can get worn out there then like we
said really they've gotten worn out in
some of their worst games just because
they're on the field every fourth play
back-to-back road games for Washington
Tennessee fighting for a playoff spot
since thereby which was a few weeks ago
the Titans are averaging 30 points per
game at home since their week for buy
which is really when it evaporated for
Washington they started off like 3 and 1
and now New Orleans was right after the
buy they haven't scored over 23 points
in any game since week 4 hmm that's
amazing
Titans win 27 to 12 and I am putting
$100 on the Titans to cover the 10
getcha Josh Johnson how's that win
delicious I imagine Jackson what a
comfortable place to play the Titans
love the Jaguars but guess what
Washington we hear that you're bringing
a Gruden into town entire family has
dreamed of becoming a Titan but guess
what next game on Saturday 820 on
Saturday night the Baltimore Ravens
visiting the Los Angeles charger spread
in this game is La - four and a half
Chris okay this is uh one of my favorite
games of the week and of course it
should be everybody's favorite game of
the weekend I mean just the meaning
everything it has to it Chargers can
still be the number one seed if they win
and the Chiefs lose
Baltimore's fighting for their life to
stay into the play on the line I mean I
always talk about every defense hat and
every unit has their kryptonite in the
NFL the NFL is the ultimate humbling
experience because at some point you're
gonna meet your match somewhere along
the lines and this to me is the match
that the Los Angeles chargers defense
does not want to see they'd rather see
the Kansas City Chiefs and Patrick
mahomes in this unit that's coming at
them this weekend so I guess that's my
first big question of the day is you
know or just the the question I posed to
everybody out there
the Chargers once again are the smallest
defense in football I don't know that if
that's statistically accurate I'm just
going by my eye and I'm telling you that
they are I would think that the numbers
bear that out as well okay I mean when
you got like I said the middle
Bakkar there's only one of them in there
he's 220 pounds okay then Phillips the
Safety's the other guy in there he's 210
pounds and then Damien's square who I've
told you a million times two hundred and
ninety pounds now so your notes right
about the Chargers d4 yes you wrote they
got to be smallest front four right
right you also wrote the Chargers D is
so fast you're not gonna win sideline
the sideline even though some screens
works and misdirection yes right so the
speed of the Chargers might be the
fastest in the NFL it's real yes I mean
when you take the two guys on the edge
with Melvin and Bosa you're not gonna
win that race you're not gonna win the
race to the sidelines against Durham
when James right ah linebackers Phillips
31 like I told you yeah they're
phenomenal playing that cycle that the
Ravens really want to get into no the
Ravens want to come on in
we got we got 330 we got 320 we got 305
oh we got back to 320 and then we got
345 oh i wide receivers are slow but it
doesn't matter because we got one two
three four tight ends that love to block
that's right so the the Ravens are gonna
go straight ahead I would be shocked if
that's not the deal early on it's gonna
be Gus Edwards in the middle Lamar in
the middle ticks and then when they
start to feel like the Chargers are
pinching the gaps right Andrews over the
top you're gonna add that and you'll get
Lamar around the edge as soon as they
start to feel like okay they're pinching
everybody which that was my big question
from your notes yeah is when the Mar
goes around the edge right is he gonna
get the edge because of all the speed
for the charge yeah no I mean he might
not break it for 20 or 30 but I think
he'll get the edge and Nuggets a third
and five
exactly or maybe get the 10 yard I would
think so I mean if not then then that's
where the game will be one I really will
be right that was my big question and I
I would think that the Ravens are going
to use the type of scheme to in the run
game where I always call gap scheme
which is like they try to find double
teams across the board and just go
forward right let's go forward let's
double-team the three technique and then
as we start to push him back to the
second level one will get on the
linebacker
and now the running back weaves his way
through there so I see that could happen
now switching it to the other side
yes the Ray the Ravens defense of course
is a very good matchup for the Chargers
offense as well
the Ravens defense is certainly it's
either the second best defense in
football or the third best defense in
football it's one of the other and they
can do everything in the secondary
that's what's awesome about the the
Ravens defense if they want to play
man-to-man they got the horses to do it
if they want to play creative zone Don
Martin did or wink Martindale he of
course has the ability and knowledge and
creativity to figure that out so I look
at that as advantage Baltimore to a
degree Melvin Gordon playing that will
be huge because if he's not out there
and it's to pass heavy that really
swings in the favor of Baltimore
big-time but regardless I think the
Ravens are gonna win the football game
nice this is one of my upsets of the
week I'm picking the Ravens to win 20 to
17 and I'm putting 730 dollars
heavy-hitter go for a gallon I can't do
the ravenous
Edgar Allen don terry poe and it doesn't
get hit by bolts of lightning I repeat I
on the tribe felt like a crazy guy I
tried to get my inner sneagle you also
just spit all over me I totally did but
I'm the only one that's not sick in this
room so that's what I'm taking away so
the one thing that I've been noticing
with the Chargers as I constantly call
them out and they prove me wrong is they
love to do the slow start and a late
surge down 14 - the cheese came back
that Bengals game was 14 at 12 and then
they kind of surged ahead at the end
right Steelers down two scores came back
guys they started down 10 nothing to
Arizona and then scored 45 right the
difference is I look at those teams
Chiefs Bengals Steelers Cardinals you
know what they don't have the Ravens
defense right so a lot of what I'm
seeing there is I think the Ravens are
gonna set the tone and then it's gonna
come down to can they withstand the
Philip Rivers lead hurry up offense
surge and I believe they are able to
handle that the Ravens aren't looking to
be fast they're not gonna get worn down
and like you said Keenan Allen is hurt
might not play Melvin Gordon banged up
and the Chargers just won a huge game
last week right and in the Ravens they
got accused of being out Baltimore and
Baltimore like in a public forum yeah
and it was slippery and it was sloppy
and Lamar didn't play his best game I
think the Ravens win as well I have them
winning 23 to 17 I will admit that you
have impacted me here this is not
completely my own thought oh no that's a
good thing I am putting a hundred and
fifty dollars on Baltimore to cover this
I think the fact that it's four and a
half I expected it to be a Chargers by
three right but the four and a half like
that's a big margin to beat Baltimore
it's just a really good team where I
think the Chargers are a team that play
from behind a lot and I
think that they might the Chargers could
win this game at the end and completely
prove us wrong yeah I just don't think
you're winning by a touchdown yeah I
would have a hard song the way you like
the other one better I do I know you
lost your Raven voice I don't even
remember what it my oh it's somewhat
causes Senden am i okay Spanish no you
were in Spanish you're like cows started
left Korean there is all right guys
moving on Sunday at one o'clock the
Cincinnati Bengals on the road visiting
the Cleveland Browns spread in this game
Chris is Cleveland minus seven and a
half the huge acts an interception ball
revenge game baby
how dare you do that to Hugh I know we
can't do that okay um Cleveland's
playing good football they are there's
no there's no II mean their one loss out
of the last five games is the Houston
Texans and you know that was a pick six
Baker threw three interceptions in the
first half and kind of got behind the
eight ball there and that didn't work
out in their favor but the defense has
played better we've talked about the
offense a hundred times over the last
few weeks how they're playing through
the run game doing all that so I have a
hard time thinking that the Bengals
defense which has been slightly better
lately since they got rid of Terrell
Austin I'm not gonna sit here and tell
you it's anything great but it's been
better but nonetheless the fact that
it's in Cleveland and the formula which
Cleveland plays with on the offensive
side of the ball and the way Baker is
throwing it yeah I have a hard time
sitting here and going oh the yeah the
Bengals are gonna make a lot of plays or
stop the Cleveland Browns from from
moving the ball up and down the field
now the bang goes on the other hand for
what they bring to the table on the
offensive side of the ball hey it's the
Joe Mixon show I don't think there's any
doubt about that they're trying to do
that Driscoll's gonna scramble a few
times and then he's gonna look for Boyd
occasionally in the past banged up yeah
right so so between all of that the
bangles winning a game last week for the
first time in forever and I still think
Cleveland's a team that's truly build
for the future and trying to build on
something I am putting ten dollars in
the Cleveland Browns I'm taking the
Browns 28 to 20
I do think that the Bengals might keep
this interesting for a little while and
then it's you know 14 all or something
like that 14 13 I think the Browns pull
away maybe the Bengals correlate touch
down and make it an eight point loss so
the Hugh Jackson interception ballgame
remember that was the game of which Andy
Dalton got hurt also right Mixon only
had 14 carries in that game because
Cleveland went out four touchdowns like
that ever so we changed the pace of
pleasure
Cincinnati's coming off a solid win but
I think the Browns are coming off of a
bigger emotional win going into Denver
in primetime running that win the
Bengals in a weird way have been a solid
road team this year
they really honestly have their bigger
losses have come at home yeah the last
two games for Joe Mixon 26 carries 27
carries the Bengals have found their
identity on offense where before it was
14 15 13 11 26 and 27 and I don't think
the Browns have that great of a running
defense over all right Browns have
executed well at home and what Baker did
against the Bengals 258 four touchdowns
no interceptions is great but I'm
looking at a Browns team that I don't
think is ready to start being a seven
and a half point favorite over anybody I
look at this Browns team two of the
younger players just get to the Pro Bowl
I don't know if they're ready to handle
a playoff push the Bengals get to be
spoilers and not only are they spoilers
they're spoilers with revenge in their
mouth because they're sitting there
going damn gee how many memes like how
many videos came out of that last game
the David and joke who carry into the
end zone the Hugh Jackson getting a
football the Bengals for that entire
week were like wow you got a suck right
I think Driscoll's done a pretty good
job of managing the game yes and I also
think that Joe mix-ins hitting that next
level right now is I think the Browns I
think the Browns pull out a very close
win at home but I don't think they're
covering seven and a half I'm going $50
on the Bengals
Wow
hello Leon in there that is literally
the sound of me on a Saturday morning
it's me just like ripping one and then
me like they're like more comes out all
right guys next game on Sunday I got me
some like mating or something the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers on the road visiting the
Dallas Cowboys spread in this game Chris
is Dallas - 7 Dallas - 7 ok alright so
you go to your thing and I'll sprinkle
in some of your film notes ok about the
cowboy yeah sure um you know the Cowboys
defensively verse the Bucks offense
let's just start there I don't think
that the I don't think the Cowboys
d-line can make a mess of this game as
far as just absolutely ruining it
against this Tampa Bay off it's a lot
it's the first thing I'll say I don't
think they gonna make a mess of it it's
one of the number one units that I
thought was going to stink this year
that's a little bit better
yes definitely Tampa Bay's offensive and
defensive lines I just assumed we're
gonna be crap and they're a lot better
than they are yeah they are you're
exactly right I mean that's where this
conversation is going to go so and I do
I mean I'm I'm with you there as far as
they're one of the surprise units in
football this year they have good size
up front to where you know there's good
size decent athletes and no matter who
they face this had a hard time really
you know ruining the game and that dimin
that way whether there was the Saints
last two weeks ago or the Ravens last
week now the Cowboys will present I
think some opportunities in the past
game for the Bucs - just because the
Bucs are extremely aggressive the
Cowboys are kind of aggressive - and
like you saw last week with the Colts
there was a few plays that Andrew Luck
had some ability to get a little
protection hit them downfield on some
passes you wrote this in your film
review of Colts Cowboys right terms of
the defense this will be the game plan
for teams with a good offensive line
against the Cowboys going forward you
wrote specifically the Saints will watch
this film spread Dallas out yeah make
them simpler yes you expect the Bucks to
do that I do to a degree I think that
when are they capable do they yes they
are I don't know if they're quite as
capable as the call
bolts and things like that but I would
think there's moments yes where you
spread them out if you feel confident
that your old line can go five on four
against their four and hold their own
right I think you're more favorable
there than my point being like the
Saints that Saints tried to do these
condense formations and all this time of
stuff where Dallas had blowed had yeah
right and they had eleven guys in there
with them and none of them were more
than fifteen yards deep so when they're
all their eyes are on the quarterback in
the drive condensed you might have a
hole in the running game but as soon as
you get to the hole there's four guys
there cuz they're all there so I think
that was something I took away from what
the Colts did they said whoa they're
really fast they're really aggressive
they keep your eyes on the quarterback
and we're all in your condensed we might
open up a hole but a linebacker or
safeties gonna be in that hole by the
time our running back gets there so that
was my point of that so but I do think
that Tampa Bay like I was saying there
would be some place to present itself in
the past game you might see Mike Evans
have some big plays I don't think it's
gonna happen consistently but I think
you could see some of that now if I flip
it over to the other side I don't think
this is the greatest matchup in the
world for the Dallas Cowboy offense I
was encouraged with what I saw from the
Bucks defense last week again vitae via
had moments of popping they are a big
defensive line as we've talked about
over the last few be I'm big dude it's
as big as it gets really with McCoy and
via in the middle and then jpp and NASA
and you could throw the Vinny curries of
the world in there when they want to get
big right and all that so I do think
they can slow down the Dallas run game
to a degree and Tampa in the back ends
of applying the right way lately they're
not overly talented but they're not
doing dumb things they're not taking
chances they're not putting their guys
on Islands against guys that they can't
match up against which is the key
because in your notes about the Cowboys
offense you wrote the Cowboys have to
find plays in the passing game that
aren't just one man doing something
special exactly we talked about this on
Monday's pod dak is great in man-to-man
right and the question I guess would
have for you is do you think the Bucks
are gonna present those opportunities I
don't I don't think very much and then
you're probably gonna go opposite on
this pick as well sounding well and I
mean I think you know just think about
like for anybody else listening like
Omari Cooper's big plays that you saw it
over the last month
thanksgiving against the redskins it was
a slant verse man-to-man you know he
breaks the tackle
it was another go route vers man-to-man
the plays against the eagles a few weeks
ago we're man-to-man you know even the
great routes we see him run a long time
ago what a route it's a post corner vers
man-to-man yeah you know tampa is not
gonna let those opportunities happen a
lot i actually I'm putting $10 on the
Dallas Cowboys okay I put I picked a
push did you I did I picked the Cowboys
to win 24 to 17 mmm yeah so I I kind of
knew that this is where you were gonna
go yeah it really is a blueprint to beat
the Cowboys is it's the blueprint to
honestly beat any technology that's
right of course yes really good front
for AI and smart enough to not put the
offense in a good situation with
man-to-man Dallas I think when I look at
these two teams what makes me more
confident in the Cowboys is the last
game Dallas needs revenge over the Colts
of what just happened and when I read
your notes and from what I saw on TV
Dallas played really well they just
screwed up situational football time and
time again and AK missed some throws
that he can't miss I think the Colts are
a much more better bet better coach team
yeah than the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
I think the Bucs are eliminated I think
that what I'm seeing quotes this week of
people going on that team I can't worry
about Dirk cutter I'm worried about my
job I'm seeing a team that's mailed it
in week 16 and 17
they've mailed it in they're not playing
as hard how can they how can they play
is hard right also I went back and
looked at that Tampa Bay Baltimore game
just in terms of stats yeah
Baltimore's offense was on the field for
37 minutes
exactly they had 242 rushing yards and
got 24 first downs even though that
Tampa Bay defense has the pieces to
match up with Dallas I think that
they've got to be worn down about being
in their second Road game and facing a
similar base team that's gonna punch
them in the mouth for the second
straight week yeah all rise of that I
think tan because Tampa Bay has a
quarterback that can throw all of your
good drives away like that
I'm taking Dallas to win 34 to 20 and
I'm putting 250 dollars on the Dallas
County oh I love when there is a team
that has just lost a crucial game that
now gets to come home and fight for
their playoff lives against a team that
is now mathematically eliminated with
questions about their culture with a
quarterback that throws picks because I
also don't see any of those wide
receivers for Tampa Bay really having an
advantage either Mike Evans I'd like to
introduce you to Byron Jones yes you're
going to be a very long day yeah yeah so
I get you listen I also think Dallas is
safer at home yeah Tampa Bay has more
turnovers on the road right so all those
things are true there's no there's no
doubt about it I mean yeah I mean it
could go that way
I just Dallas storing 30-something
points is what I would just never bet on
with anything but I could see them
winning 20 24 210 right something like
that 34 I don't know if that's an idea I
just thought that Dallas is coaching
staffs gonna get together and be like we
gotta put up points though well they
might wear their ass out that's what I
could next game I wanna clock here on
Sunday the Minnesota Vikings visiting
the Detroit Lions spread in this game is
Vikings minus five and a half Chris okay
um so I I did watch Minnesota's offense
on film I think I'll just start there
hey listen there was nothing
groundbreaking other than it was an
attitude and attention towards the run
game that's all there was to it they had
a focus right there was a focus exactly
we're gonna come out and give Dalvin
cook the ball their first pass play was
a screen pass to Dalvin cook
awesome right they ran inside zone and
he found the cup backs right and they
ran again what I would call the gap
scheme 35 lead whatever it may be where
the full-back was in they had double
teams like I said one gets off to the
second level
the full-back leads and another
linebacker those were like the two runs
of the day that's what they did but it
worked and they didn't were to change it
up and then what else did we see off
that I saw more of a heavy dose of play
actions and boots that's what they did
and then when they had some one-on-ones
they hit dealing once or twice digs once
or twice it wasn't pretty
it was a nice formula I think it's
something to build on
it's the way they should play with the
way their team is built in general
anyways but now saying that all of that
that that's you know it's one thing to
do that to the Miami Dolphins again I
feel like I say this every week
but ever since Detroit's got snacks
Harrison things have changed and the
defense is out of the bull Shawn hands
on IR I don't know if that's a yeah it's
not as a huge deal it's not a huge deal
but it does hurt their rotation overall
yeah he's not a starter anymore but
either way I have a hard time sitting
here and going oh Minnesota is just
gonna move the ball or run the ball on
Detroit all day long the other thing
that scares me about Minnesota's offense
against Detroit to the predictable
nature of it and just like New England
when Patricia has a pretty good feel for
the predictable nature of an offense
he's all over it whether it was last
week the Cardinals he had a good feel
for the Rams and what they did okay I
mean he was all over the Bears and some
of their crap on Thanksgiving Day so I
guess that's the part that scares me
now when you flip it over to the other
side and talk about you know Minnesota's
defense verse Detroit offense
Minnesota's defense is good man Harry
ons officially out for the year that's
what I mean and like all you have is
Gallaudet what is there exactly right
and gala days just not gonna scare
Minnesota epsy do dunkaroo
a poops a couple of boobs yeah I mean
there's just nothing there for me to sit
there and go oh wait this is one area
Detroit has a an advantage in you know
they're just I don't see that area in
the football game
so I think Detroit's defense makes this
game uglier and closer than maybe we
would expect yes um
I'm still I'm putting $10 on the Vikings
though I had them winning hmm
I'll send on where's this game being
played as a Detroit go to Detroit I love
that you say ascend ascend it's decent
because you have to imagine that you
Detroit higher elevation in Minnesota I
don't know where exactly it's a sin no
it's it's more like you say that when
you're floating above and you go descend
it's like a launch I've heard a sound I
don't know
does people say descend do you have
statistics to bake back up here do you
yeah yeah no alright laughs go pick the
game
well did you um did you and wrap up your
point no I just I got I got twenty two
fourteen the last time these guys played
it was one of the all-time ass kicks
this NFL season I would put it right
behind
Baltimore's drubbing of Tennessee when
they had thirteen sex why because the
last time they played in Minnesota
Stafford was sacked ten times can they
barely had over 200 yards of total
offense and that was with carry on
Johnson Minnesota just had their rebirth
against Miami Detroit a late death in
Buffalo Detroit officially eliminated
from the playoffs Minnesota looking
around and going this is the football
guys we got rid of de Filippo it's
kakuka licking right now also what you
said about Patricia he only has one week
of film to really understand this team
sure that was my argument against you
yeah where Patricia looks at the last
time they played has to go it's not even
the same offensive coordinator so he has
one week to go okay they're gonna focus
on pounding with Dalvin cook what if
they don't
so really Patricia has no film to go off
of here I think Kirk and the Vikings are
on a mission I think it's a sloppy game
that the lack of offense for Detroit
becomes you know what ends up propelling
the Vikings late what did you have the
score s 20 to 14 I have it as 27 to 16
and I am putting $100 on Minnesota -
five and a half
all right guys moving on do you see that
lion I won that lion as my personal pet
I want it on this ship now I'm cool with
that long as you don't shoot it it's
cool it's gonna be my pet good Patricia
good Patricia he does kind of look like
a lion he does he looks like a lion that
just ate so I was like lions right off
the bat bucks so you're rooting against
yourself $10 DJ chump change
alright guys next game here one o'clock
on Sunday the Buffalo Bills the New
England Patriots this
this game is New England -13 Chris I
just talked through both you yeah it's
good way to do it
New England uh I mean of course come on
we've never even seen New England in
this scenario since like the last time
they didn't make the playoffs such as
2002 like is there even a stat what's
the Patriots record after back-to-back
loss I'm like I can't even I think we
had to go back to 2002 I think it's the
years let me go check it out I don't
think it's on NFL Jesus it was yeah the
2002 season though I'm pretty sure was
the last time they lost to in December
right so again Buffalo's defense is
phenomenal the last time they lost two
in a row in December they came back and
beat the Dolphins at home 27 to 28 of
the year December 29 2008 when they made
them finish what ten and six they
finished that year nine and said nine
and seven it didn't get in and they did
not yeah so but the Buffalo defense
again this is one of the best coach
units best units and all the football
there's nothing that I look at their
defense ago oh they have issues the only
time Buffalo's defense has faltered the
whole year it's just when you know they
had golfers playing quarterback and like
guys coming off the street to play
quarterback and they had no offense to
talk of at all so I still think that
Buffalo will give this New England
offense a tough time I you know New
England if there are different offense
this year I mean Brady of course is not
quite as good Gronk is not quite as good
Julian Edelman is not quite as good not
to say they're not saying they're bad
players I'm just saying they're not as
good as yours past and they're not as
good spreading the field out and
surgically destroying you like they were
in years past they want to run the ball
downhill and get in the I formation and
do all that and I think this is a tough
unit to do that with Buffalo I think
it's tough to do anything and gets
Buffalo with the way their coach and
they don't take a lot of chances and
they can rush the passer before so I do
think they'll have moments of stymieing
that New England offense now on the
other side I mean I think for the most
part of the day you're gonna see
domination from the Patriots defense
seriously I do I just I have a hard time
I think the Patriots secondary is
playing pretty good football yeah I
think the really the only thing I
questioned about the Patriots defense of
course is their front seven you know I
know I always talk about their speed
being a little slow but I mean guys like
Malcolm Brown and Lawrence guy just
haven't played
great the last two weeks I all say this
I don't think the coaches event
necessarily put them in the greatest
positions either up front the last few
weeks they've been out schemed a few
times in the run game and that's very
rare where I go the Dolphins game there
was two or three runs I'd like to ask
bill how you expect to defend this run
with this defense and then the same
thing last week against the Pittsburgh
there's a few runs where I want to go I
don't see how you can defend it with
this defense so that would be my
question they're all together but either
way I'm not crazy okay I mean I'm crazy
but I'm not
it [ __ ] insane I'm picking the
Patriots here I'm going I'm picking
Buffalo excuse me what yes for $10 so
then you did go crazy I I mean I don't
see those your score 24 to 14 like I
just still think this is where I think
this game only everything about two
sides of the ball
I cannae everything about special
mountains you're right I don't I don't
and I'm like what times that I feel like
the Patriots might get 10 points based
off a field position missed feel like
all that goodness but they they that's
where a buffalo is very good at playing
that game you know that's how they
manage being me under the not the good
team on the field every week because
they do do those things well and I'm
giving them points because of the J a
factor the J a factors real that's so
funny I mean so I have these are my two
notes right Buffalo is walking into a
wood chipper right I mean they just
survived Detroit at home and New
England's coming off double digit
colossal wood chip wood chip and I think
that this is gonna be Josh Allen's worst
game as a pro yeah I mean it's gonna be
tough because I believe that the
Patriots are gonna go don't even rush
him don't even Russia let's spread out
make the kid throw it every time and I'm
not saying that Josh Helen can't I'm
just saying that I believe the last few
weeks Josh Allen has gone running is a
huge part of my game I'm celebrated for
it and I've never seen a strictly mobile
guy beat the Patriots before yeah I've
just never seen it right I think it's a
mush rush I think the Patriots win this
game 4107
my pudding I'm putting a hundred dollars
in the patron my favor it was not about
no go please my factor is not his
running
I don't expect that to be the thing you
think there's gonna be a few
over-the-top there'll be a few throws
where they're gonna go like dim we just
didn't know he could throw at 55 yards
on a line
I think Buffalo's coming into New
England go and hey we had him in that
first half and hour quarter best
quarterback was Derek Anderson and now
they're gonna be sitting here going holy
crap
not only are the Patriots focused but
they're angry and they want to take all
of it out on us this feels like the
blowout Patriots game to rectify
everything and everyone's doubting the
end of the era and Bella checks holding
it up and going they think that you're
done that's not how he talks about
anything that you're done and then
they're gonna go in there I think this
is blowout City why are you starring
certain games firm I guaranteed two
losses oh yeah before we move on any
thoughts on Adams sweatshirt today
yeah it's pitiful shout-out to lyrical
lemonade shout out to those young dudes
making dope music videos I'm not even
explain it to you don't worry don't
waste my time okay really comfortable
sweater it looks like it yeah it does
look very calm happy well you don't like
the colors no it's fine that's I don't
even know what it is it's all good what
anybody write music no they like direct
music videos and stuff yeah it's not a
rapper's bunch of young kids making good
contact what blood rappers we talking
about what videos also the T alright
moving on next game at one o'clock here
guys the Green Bay Packers on the road
visiting the New York Jets spread in
this game is Jets - two and a half Chris
I just can't believe you're picking them
to blow Buffalo out all right there do
you know what it is I always go there's
a few teams that we think that they're
gonna keep it close and we go their
coaching is gonna keep it close and I
remember we were saying that about the
Bears when they went to Buffalo - but I
think eventually that dam breaks for
those teams and typically it happens on
the road you know Buffalo I think is a
team that's they look they play
back-to-back games at home and kept it
close yeah and their last real road game
was that I don't know package dad's
taking a whack just messing with you
don't okay Packers Jets here okay I
think that the Packers offense is gonna
have a hard time moving the ball on the
Jets the Packers just for everybody out
there they have a hard time moving the
ball against anybody if again if I have
to hear one more time this
me that oh my gosh Aaron Rodgers missed
three throws I could go back and show
you three throws that everybody missed
in football last week I could show you a
nine throws drew brees missed in the
game on Monday night I could show you
throws Tom Brady missed but nobody talks
about that because Aaron Rodgers is
under a microscope unlike anybody else
because if he doesn't deliver magic they
have no freaking chance and I'll be the
first to tell you he was off his game
last week he missed a few throws he
should know but when the dam breaks
every time you're back to throw and then
oh when it doesn't break absolutely no
one is open I mean they have guys out
there playing receiver right now that I
don't even know who they are and they're
not even worth me looking up their names
yet so I'm just telling you that right
so you about Nick Mullens threw for 400
yards and four touchdowns that's right
that's also before he planned then what
happened what happened the next week
after that and now but no either way yes
so yeah together they got to do some
things but I do think that Todd Bowles
this is again the type of offense just
like we saw last week with the Houston
Texans when New York Jets buy him that
they can scheme and game plan for okay
there they have the cover corners that
we'll be able to play man-to-man at
times but Bowles is also very good at
drawing up zone coverages like we always
talked about with some good defensive
coordinators and having people in the
right areas right and it was tough
sledding on Houston last week yes it was
you know I mean if it wasn't just Watson
making some amazing plays and throw
Hopkins catching it over people's face
exactly right I don't know how Chris
don't have either of them no they don't
have either of those um okay and then
you flip it over to the other side I
still got a lot of respect for Green
Bay's defense okay even though they just
lost Kenny Clark to IR yeah that does
hurt no doubt about it and the run game
I'm sure will be more prevalent than I
would like yes that that's definitely a
factor and really been a fan of peten
yeah I mean to me Green Bay should look
at Chicago from last year just to add
that to this little conversation and go
okay defense is good we kept Vic Fangio
Green Bay should be okay defense is good
we keep Mike Pettine
and you bring in offensive mastermind to
run that's out of the ball that's what I
think they also get more pieces yeah
they need pieces of course - yes so
but then on the other side when we talk
about the Jets offense first the Packers
defense the run game really will be the
big factor of the game if they just
dominate the line of scrimmage in the
run game they're gonna win the game
there's as plain as day but if it's kind
of a stalemate and they don't go over a
hundred yards I think they're gonna have
a tough time throwing the ball on Green
Bay too because group of course Green
Bay has cover guys Mike Pettine is a
very good smart creative defensive
coordinator okay I just think Green
Bay's got pride all right I'm just
telling you yeah I'm taking Green Bay
for $10 Wow I think pack oh I just think
it's still Aaron Rodgers they're not
gonna fold the tent and I do look at
this as being a little bit of the kind
of game without speed on the outside of
their edge rushers and the Jets where he
can make magic gotcha
and then they can play man-to-man and
the Jets but they're not like the
greatest man-to-man guys ever to wear I
think if there's nobody open he'll still
be able to fit some balls in there I
think they win an ugly 23:17 game
Packers are being motivated by
self-respect yeah
the Jets are being motivated by building
on the future right you have a young
quarterback the season isn't ever over
because you want to keep like learning
around them I have I want you to
remember the Packers are Owen seven on
the road this year who Oh in seven it's
unbelievably I had the Jets winning a
close one twenty three to twenty one and
the reason though I'm putting $50 on the
Jets is because there's still a chance
they sit Aaron Rodgers in this game he'd
said today he's playing just like you
know I just read it before we came in
here he came out and said I'm playing
Sunday so am I correct on that I believe
what was your score that you had 23 17
so I have 25 season losing like 1716 and
him making a late drive to win the game
that's really how I said I have the Jets
winning but I just want to put my money
on the Jets here I'm taking the home
team home team that played really well
against a good Houston team last week
and I'm also thinking Sam's gonna go
back there and go wow I mean I played
well against Jadeveon Clowney and
Whitney merciless and Bernard Kerik
McKinney and
JJ Watt and now who's coming to town
like who like who's a guy on Green Bay
that's physically scaring anybody on the
Jets ya know there's it's not there's
nothing like that the strength of the
corners guys are closely the strength of
the Packers defense right the Jets don't
even have guys that like they're not
even trying to get it going on the
outside I just think the Jets they get
the running game going I don't know the
running game from no faith in the pack
so I hear you on the road yep
all right guys next game at 1 o'clock
moving on here Houston on the road
visiting Philadelphia spread in this
game is Philadelphia - to Chris Sims oh
man this is a doozy here this is one of
those things that I wish I had a little
bit more time to let this game digest
throughout the week how come I'm open
did Philly plus three and a half by the
way because how it's - - Wow
because I am literally like I just
stopped watching last week 12 minutes
before this shows like you already
watched Philly's all right and then ya
know I know I just you know as the Week
comes out matchups come to my brain I've
could be sitting on the back porch
Saturday night and go oh man that that
could be the game work right there those
things like come to fruition at times
okay but either way Houston's D verse to
Philly oh yeah yeah okay
the biggest question about Houston's D
is their secondary I mean we were just
talking about their Jets matchup last
week if Cherise Wright is playing
man-to-man you throw at Cherise right
and that's basically with the Jets did
Oh Charisse right he hasn't covered
anybody in four years we're gonna throw
him okay that was good so that's a
concern I had if he's still in the
league it's amazing and but dave has up
there with injuries and bangs yeah cam
was the same kind of a wild liked one of
my tweets recently yeah and I was like
if only you knew but the he was the had
a videotape on Mike Tomlin guy he oh is
that what it was no that's what you like
this guy must have video yeah he's got
some blackmail material to still be
making the roster the Houston defense
verse the Philly offense though I this
not as good a matchup for the Philly
offense as the Rams were last week okay
they're not gonna bludgeon you know the
Houston Texas defense with the straight
ahead run game or make them have to
worry about it that way I mean I do look
at this game as going no they're gonna
have to win this one for sure with the
pass game of Nick voles can they come up
with enough creative plays and explosive
plays in that department to beat the
Houston Texans I don't know how I feel
about that because the Houston like I've
told you the weakness of their football
team is they do let up too many big
plays in the pass game I think at times
they take too many chances to and try to
do a little too creative stuff and
leaves them compromised in other areas
now when I flip it over to the other
side - I don't think the Houston is
going to be able to run the ball much on
the Philadelphia Eagles I think that's
gonna be a tough matchup
I think Houston it's gonna have a pretty
tough time pass protecting with deshaun
Watson - deshaun Watson is the most
pressured quarterback in the NFL yeah so
there you go and he's not afraid to hold
on to it and take a sack because he will
wait for that guy down the field to come
open and sometimes he hits umber 50-yard
touchdown sometimes he gets sacked so
that's part of it
but I still think at the end of the day
your pass rush is not as dominant as
years past and there's not gonna be the
interior mismatch that the Eagles had
against the Rams last week they're not
just gonna Bowl over the Houston Texans
Houston has a legit pretty good run game
- aware you're gonna have to at least
put some eggs into that basket - stop it
you're not gonna just go our front four
can stop it it's not gonna happen
because of the DeSean watched and read
option stuff and all of that off of it
so at the end of the day what I'm
telling you is I think to be a close
football game but I'm putting $10 in the
Houston Texans and I think they're gonna
win the game 2721 so I said that DeSean
Watts was the most pressure quarterback
second straight row game for Houston a
lot of pressure on Houston to try and
get that bye yeah Eagles coming off an
enormous win the Texans and Oilers have
never beaten the Eagles oh and their
entire existence how about the Titans
because they were the Oilers I have the
Eagles winning 24 to 23 oh the Titans
beat that's a Houston cover which we had
someone on Twitter ago that's the
dumbest thing possible you
the team wins like it's like the
percentages are so high that they also
cover but I have the Eagles winning 24
to 23 but that's a Houston plus 2 cover
so I'm putting $50 in the Houston Texas
budget
all right guys next game at Walla so you
took you you took you're taking Houston
to cover but Philly to win yes ok 24:23
yeah which like shouldn't be a thing
apparently why I don't even get that
that's right I'm the team that wins also
covers is that right yeah like eighty
percent of time is that right for so
most the time the team them wins they
cover but but you guys a guy on Twitter
pointed out that you guys will always
pick a team to win but not cover yeah
you're right which is one left goes
brick yeah and I was saying you're right
that's probably like our biggest flaw
yeah but the way that we've both started
doing it now is we both predict the
scores right and then we go solely based
off the score right which is I think
more fun cuz then you look down you're
like it was six yeah because the betting
you guys were breaking down the game's
the betting is just for fun no it's also
for pride for the fifth alright guys
here we go second year ready we're going
can't keep no over two years two years
so this will be the third straight year
second year we did I've definitely be
it's the second year the betting
clarification I I don't I don't we
picked five games a week for the first
two years and you beat me in that this
is the second year this and your want to
know fine but in all formats this will
be the fifth straight year it will be
okay here we go
moving on in three two one all right
guys next game at one o'clock here on
Sunday the Atlanta Falcons on the road
visiting the Carolina Panthers spread in
this game Carolina - two and a half and
we did hear today that the Panthers are
shutting Cam Newton down for the rest of
the season yeah I think that came in
know that we're discussing it I think it
came out of fishel I know just as I was
doing it I saw something out there that
probably why I could change my rap
report reported Panthers are expected to
sit Cam Newton now that they're out of
the playoff race did the line change I
can check that for you hold on lines
definitely changed yeah it's a Carolina
plus three and a half alright so what we
want to do here no I think we should do
it at Carolina plus three and a half
switch it to Carolina plus three and a
half yeah because the other one's not
real
stick okay so Carol so now it's Atlanta
- three and a half correct
okay does that change your scoring yes
it does yeah do you want to take a
second here and figure that out
no I don't care it's not really really
taking a second who gives a crap about
this
take it away okay um Panthers defense
still very good okay I mean I was
encouraged about what I saw against the
Saints the other night
okay and even just watching it back on
film a little while ago
Hey the I have a hard time thinking that
the Falcons are gonna go up and down the
field on the Carolina Panthers
especially it being in Carolina
Carolina's pass-rush of course is the
biggest issue with their football team
but I think with the simpleness of the
past scheme of Atlanta on that side of
the ball
I do NSA they might fire both cordon
sounds that way right so I have a hard I
have a hard time thinking Atlanta is
going to move the ball consistently on
the Panthers defense throughout the day
now the Atlanta defense against the
Panthers offense you know I don't know
what to think about the Panthers offense
with Cam Newton things change so much
here they're going to have to become
traditional a little bit some of the
movement stuff and all the misdirection
things they do behind the line of
scrimmage because you have to worry
about Cam Newton running the ball that
kind of gets lost in the shuffle here so
that goes away I originally had the
Panthers winning the game when I thought
cam was gonna win I had him won in like
a three point game like a 23-20 game
yeah at home I just thought they would
play for pride and win one here and not
in this season but now that he's out
I'm gonna go Falcons 20 Panthers 17 and
I just think that mastery and Carolina
cover I do I have a Carolina cover still
I think that the yeah Matt Ryan and
company make one or two plays yeah I
probably should lower that 17 it's tight
it's Taylor Heinicke so let's go 20 to
10 Falcons so you're going Atlanta for
$10 sorry I had this even with cam
playing in Atlanta winning 27 to 17 and
the main reason is I think the Falcons
are one of those franchises that when
they get eliminated they're like let's
pile up some wins like let's everything
start clicking
Dion Jones is back we're feeling good I
honestly was like off Camden plays with
a bum shoulder like just watching that
game on Monday night he was capable of
anything
yeah and the frustration - of all the
receivers looking back at him when he
would lead them too much because he's
trying to get it out there cuz his arm
strength isn't there yeah
but Taylor Heinicke like get out of here
I got $100 on Atlanta - three and a half
both so I tweeted out during the game
Monday night then I believe that the
Carolina Panthers are arguably the most
frustrating team in the NFL this season
mm-hmm and it was retweeted a lot like a
lot of Panther fans where I agree and
then the Cowboys fans like you don't
know what it's like for us or Atlanta
but really Carolina has been leading or
has been dominating so many of the games
this year and that's why I call them the
most frustrating team Green Bay is not
frustrating they're just not good right
Carolina had a good team yeah and just
found ways to lose it with missed field
goals or with bad decision-making and I
they really I think took the cake them
in Jacksonville are the most frustrating
teams yeah I mean yeah I mean Carolina
was I mean Carolina it was six and two
damn I thought they were one of the ten
teams at that point halfway through the
year where I said they can go to the
Super Bowl no team has started off the
first eight games six and two and then
finished the season six and ten Wow so
if they end up losing the last two games
they'll be the first team ever
to go six and two to six and two that's
pretty amazing all right guys next game
here at one o'clock the New York Giants
on the road visiting the Indianapolis
Colts spread in this game Chris is in D
- nine and a half yep okay um very
interesting game I think that I look at
the Colts offense and I don't think it's
a good matchup for the bear the Giants
defense I think that was the first place
I would start the Colts are tough to
defend their creativity's reel their
ability to run the ball between the
tackles is real Frank Reich and company
find a cute way to run the ball outside
every week whether it's you know bunch
crunch or pulling guards out on the edge
however you want to say it so there's
that to worry about there's an
aggressive downfield passing game
to worry about with maybe the best
downfield passer in the game right now
in Andrew Luck ooh
nobody can dial up more down the field
throws and put pressure on you just like
we say with all great offenses
the Colts make you defend the whole
field if they have like another weapon
on their offense they had one more what
they really they would be like oh they
be a handful to deal with right or even
another great receiver whatever it may
be but yes so that that is definitely an
issue but so I look at that as being
really tough on the New York Giants I do
I mean scheme wise creativity with
creativity-wise i think favors the colts
you know pure brute strength favors the
colts definitely now to flip it over to
the other side okay the Giants of course
are dangerous they can make plays ATS
sake 1 you know it's a qualm barkley do
we know what the status with Odell is
yeah yeah I'm still not sure don't know
I mean the Giants of course are capable
of making plays in on the offensive side
of the ball you know even with you know
our man sterling Shepard he can do
things but I think with when it's all
said and done I still like this Colts
defense it's a little overrated right
now it's a little overrated people are
like Oh Col Steve fess is so good it's
good
they don't blow assignments yes they
have you're good right so your your
Colts defense of note you said first
thing you always notice with Indy their
linebackers cover so much ground and
save the defense exactly right and
that's where I think it will not be a
huge sake while Berkeley day because we
both say the Cowboys offense Zeke was
like one hand away five or six times
from going 60 if the game didn't get out
of hand and become 7 nothing Zeke is
going to run for 150 yards at least in
the game but Leonard and those guys
cover so much ground yeah they really do
fix a lot of mistakes they fix a lot of
mistakes it's like the Ryan shazier
effect right with those two that's how I
look at it like the the Colts tee line
has good depth it's not perfect yet but
there's some things that players they
have in a right way but yes they will
stun and do things like that and leave
gaping holes and then Walker and Darius
Leonard have to make up for it and more
times or not they do also what the Colts
do is they just don't give you a whole
lot of opportunity
on the backend to make big plays they
play safe they play conservative
throughout the day they're gonna make
you earn it they're not going bump and
run Amari Cooper on their own 20 and go
well we'll just roll the dice here and
he runs Baez we're screwed but if he
doesn't we might get a stop they don't
do that they're not at that so I'm going
$10 on the Colts okay and as I'm talking
this game out my brain I'm going I
should have bet more that's probably Wow
but I'm taking the Colts to win this one
31 to 20 okay yeah
so the first thing is and I got this
information from Nikki G our audio guy
found dare you Nikki G he said this he
goes the funny thing about the Giants
they always seem to play better on the
road
yeah there are certain teams where the
pressure of home can be a lot I also
think MetLife not the greatest place to
play but I look at them on the road blew
out Washington competitive with the
Eagles beat the Niners took the Falcons
down to the very last second took the
Panthers down to the last second one at
the Texans lost by a touchdown on the
Cowboys they've actually played really
well on the road this year Jerry
interesting yeah I also think that the
Giants offense is better in AD in a dome
yeah sure I think Eli is better in a
dome no doubt that stuff yep I have a
very interesting fact here for you who
would you say are the three franchises
that are closest and mean the most to
Eli Manning and the story of his career
the Saints Giants and the Colts I would
argue that it's the Chargers Giants and
the Colts because the Chargers were the
team that he turned down right those are
the three teams that he's never beaten
hmm he's obviously never beaten the
Giants but he's never beaten the
Chargers and he's never beaten big Bros
now you can never do that never gonna do
it not gonna happen
I look at this game and I think that
this is the the Giants are coming off of
a beat-down where they were shutout and
the Colts are coming off of beat down
where they shut somebody out I don't
know if Odell plays I hope he does but I
see the Colts winning a close one and
the Giants are actually gonna put up
some points in this game
I think the Colts win this game 31 to 26
and I'm putting $100 on the Giants to
cover this game okay
i am i think that this not gonna do that
though not gonna do that but there is
part of me that goes man is eli gonna
cross the Colts off and possibly get the
win i don't see it happening
i think the Colts are a very well-run
team but i think the Giants are gonna
keep it close yeah I really do yeah I
don't think that's that crazy
all right guys load L plays last game at
one o'clock here on Sunday the
Jacksonville Jaguars on the road
visiting the Miami Dolphin is brought in
this game dolphins - phone I'm actually
excited for this game like there's like
a few things that are exciting okay
let's hear but take us through
absolutely nothing is exciting about
this game what do you got how do a
Florida I love it $10 I'm betting $10 on
the Miami Dolphins and I think they're
gonna win 22:10 oh I guess I give the
Jacksonville Jaguars a little bit of a
fighting chance of course I'm always on
the defense
yeah oh because of that defense and
dolphins run defense always scares me
and I do get a little worried do we know
who's starting a quarterback for
Jacksonville Yetta they said because I
know Bordeaux's was in the in the
conversation this week right and you
gotta worry about the bordel scrambling
factor as well and this if that's the
case but either way moving on I don't
see anything really fulfilling in that
game to talk about you know it's really
funny yeah is this is one of the games
I'm most confident in yeah yeah it's the
NFL's second best home team at covering
the spread right Miami
believe their 5 and 1 maybe even 601
think they're 6 and 1 against the
league's second worst road team at
covering the spread I am putting $200 on
the Miami Dolphins to cover the four
points one more time because there's
$200 on it
Miami is one of the best home team
covers in the NFL we just saw them go
and hang tooth and nail with the New
England Patriots the game before that
knocked off the Buffalo Bills the game
before that held the Jets to six points
in the win the game before that kind of
messed up against Detroit but the game
before that they upset the Bears it's a
miracle they won some of this game it's
something they are so different at home
but I look at Jacksonville Leonard
fournette comes out yeah why aren't they
running me more Jalen Ramsey comes out
I'm not gonna talk about Doug Marrone
job Miami is still fighting for the
playoff spot and they feel disrespected
and they're at home coming off of being
dismantled by the Vikings Jacksonville
the season is done and I believe that
they are the bully and when they were
clicking they loved bullying right but
when a bully gets punched in the mouth
they go home and they cry yeah and
that's what the Jacksonville Jaguars are
doing yeah and what they did against
Washington that defense has to have no
hope for that offense and I have to
imagine that Adam GaSe is looking at
that film and going let's kill them when
they're down
I think Miami wins this game did I pick
a score 26 to 14 12 point win and I got
$200 on Miami I got you does it make
sense I mean nothing in betting $200 in
Miami never makes sense but I like
betting all the teams that are still
fighting for a playoff spot against the
teams that are like wow our season's
over
yeah I got jacks well didn't get any big
Pro Bowlers right no there's there's
definitely issues there 73 degrees in
Miami on Sunday only 66% humidity so
sickly what 66 66 lowest humidity in
Miami of a game especially that's that
out probably well all right moving on to
the late afternoon games 405 first one
here the Los Angeles Rams on the road I
just want to say one quick note yeah TV
Guide Alert for everybody out there the
great thing about this week since we now
know that there's teams that don't
matter those teams there are there's one
game at 1 o'clock
that really matters there's one game at
four o'clock and Sunday night nothing is
gonna distract you the one o'clock game
is well Saturday we get Baltimore
Chargers the one o'clock game is Houston
Philly the four o'clock game is gonna be
Pittsburgh New Orleans and Kansas City
Seattle at night all the other games
really don't matter unless you're in
your fantasy championship or your
gambling degenerate great I mean I
tampered Dallas has gotten meaning
I mean Houston Phillies got meaning so I
said that's the one one okay okay and
then wait there was one other one and
Giants Colts got meaning I mean to one
of those teams yeah okay I'm saying of
the teams where there's two teams that
it matters yes there's only one moment
one out for right Sunday night 405 on
Sunday the LA Rams on the road visiting
the Arizona Cardinals spread in this
game is LA - thirteen and a half quick
quick quick question before you do this
I'm seeing reports right now that Steve
Wilkes is expected to be fired at the
end of the season what it what do you
think is happening in an organization
when when the first year isn't even over
and they're going we need to move on
like what are they seeing that they're
going we already knew they feel that he
is in over his head is what I've been
told by people yes that they're just not
a that wasn't quite ready for this job I
don't know the specifics so I won't be
able to tell you anything like that but
I did know about this last week that he
was our they were already talking about
maybe this is a one and done type of
thing I know I'm a little surprised -
and I'm surprised that they're also
reporting that it's you know Steve Kim
is going to get a free pass and maybe
getting one more year and you know again
it just shows you that when you're
friends with the owner damn do you get a
lot of free passes they do hang out a
lot I do my only other question would be
everyone expected the Cardinals to be
three and 13 right so why are we I guess
it that would have to be something that
you're there to see in a daily basis the
other coaches are saying something yes
the the owner the GM they're all seeing
things done and going you shouldn't do
it that way or what's he doing or he
seems flustered I don't have the answer
for you there yeah I just know that I
just got surprising I'm with
you I I did too you know I do think it's
a little bit of a rush to judgment the
biggest mistake he made in his career to
this point was just the fact that he
hired Mike McCoy as his offensive
coordinator that's where it all starts
right because the defense is been good
in a lot of moments again there would be
another team out argue when they haven't
been good it's just cuz their offense
screws them over the game there I
haven't watched the film yet last week
though the game there early on was
Atlanta's gonna have a tough time moving
the ball and then it was pick six pick
six another pick I believe and all of a
sudden that's goes damn we're in a game
that we're not able to play here yeah so
I think that we have to keep that into
consideration a course they're playing a
pissed-off Rams team this week I have no
faith in the Cardinals offense and oddly
enough I've kind of liked what I've seen
from the Rams defense the last two weeks
huh I thought they played pretty good
against the Chicago Bears they did only
let up 16 points and they were putting
in a lot of crappy positions right you
know even last week there was moments of
good
they had like two or three Braves where
they blew assignments like the Bob Joe
Jeffery talked about I don't know what I
keep Talib was guessing he thought they
were gonna get the post over the top and
somebody come into the corner right he
was gonna I'm gonna steal the corner
interception they left the post and they
left the post over the top right so
there was little things like that
so I have a hard time thinking Arizona
moves the ball in the Rams the Rams are
gonna be pissed I will say this I didn't
a Rams offenses in a funk I think this
slowly starts to get out them out of it
this week but I don't think they're
gonna put up like 40 points this week I
don't
I think this Steve Wilkes is here in
these damn conversations too I bet you
there's guys on his defense that don't
like it either
but I don't know I just have a hard
feeling with the Rams I'm taking the
ranch or $10 yeah but it's like an ugly
24 to 9 type of win that's what I'm
going with
Shaun McVeigh nightmare for the
Cardinals the Rams are three and out
straight up and against the spread and
in those games they've won by an average
of twenty seven point seven points sir
three Noah gets the spread against the
cards you're saying yeah okay I have the
Rams win this one thirty one two three
yeah this is an embarrassing Sunday
night loss this is a Cardinals team that
their offensive line is decimated on
something that they're no I'm saying the
Rams just lost them
in primetime right I think that the
Cardinals they have Chandler Jones but
they really don't have anybody else and
I really don't see any defensive tackles
that can take advantage of the guards
that you mentioned yeah I know I don't
see them having the pieces right um and
I think that the Cardinals I I really
don't have faith in rosin with that
offensive line handling Aaron Don scary
rosin has been lately either fumbling
the ball or throwing interceptions at a
very alarming rate right a rate that
makes me look at him and goes damn I'm
worried about you now moving to the
future cuz I see Sam darn 'old has shown
growth
Lamar Jackson's shown growth and Rosen
doesn't have a lot of help around not
even the same buddy but but I want to
say neither does Allen but Allen has
physical tools to make it better
it was your big concern about rose and
his inability to move yeah I have $100
in the Rams - 13 in the yep totally
understand it
alright guys next game the 405 hear the
Chicago Bears on the road visiting the
San Francisco 49ers spreading this game
Chris is Chicago - 4 ok Chicago
- Chicago I go ok so we talk about the
49ers their offense verse the Chicago
Bears defense that's gonna be the
matchup of the day that I'm excited to
watch of course the Kyle Shanahan zone
scheme and all those things they do
against the Chicago Bears your notes
yeah was a love letter to - Kyle
Shanahan he wrote down Kyle's
understanding of the Seattle scheme is
next level Seattle was sick of being
exposed and at the end they went to man
to man you just wrote so many times
holy crap like Kyle was inside the
locker room it felt like it was like
Jacksonville last year like fer Seattle
right you remember when Jacksonville
went to San Francisco at the end of the
year how did you know this same type of
thing like Seattle with the
fourth-quarter finally said he
understands our defense let's just play
man-to-man and stop trying to I just I
just don't think that Vic Fangio is a
scheme that you understand exactly right
I think that's where I've seen that gets
exposed just about putting their
athletes in good position they do all
little bit of everything they always
have one or two things as they bring out
for the specific game that week you and
I know their front seven I mean I think
I don't know if it's the top and
football it's top two or three it's the
top in my opinion it's the best front
seven row kwan smith lately has got even
better so he's gone to the next level
watching him and Danny Trevathan before
a snap yeah Munich a right you could
tell he's now a sophomore
yes he's no longer or no and he's
playing like you can see the physical
bills and the explosive season come
anymore exactly right he's free to play
those two combined are really spent yeah
the deal so the Niners offenses creative
as it is and they might make a few plays
don't get me wrong I just think as the
end of the day the scheme and the talent
on the Bears defense will just be a
little too much for the 49ers offense
for me to sit here and go oh they're
gonna gash them consistently yeah that's
an issue now when you fold it over to
the other side you wrote down yeah san
francisco's d line might be the most
underrated in the NFL yes the other guy
that we got as a snub for the Pro Bowl
right to Forrest Buckner yes everybody
was hitting me up about him he's a
monster okay and finally grown into it
he really has but yes they are a group
that lacks a superstar or a guy that
people the public will know unless
you're really paying attention then he
know what the four is Buckner but it's
good across the board yeah that's the
big thing it's everything I hope so
they've drafted like yeah I know no guy
is overmatched there they can match up
against any personnel set on an
offensive line you know I like what
Robert Saleh does on a weekly basis yes
it's Seattle scheme but he doesn't live
in it which I always think Kyle's in his
ear going like don't live in this man
somebody's gonna figure it out and
expose this you know you got to change
it up whatever it may be I do think the
49ers will give the Bears offense a
tough time I have a hard time thinking
the Bears are gonna run the ball
consistently I think the big thing is
will the Bears catch the 49ers and those
few snaps where they do get real
creative and become aggressive
that's where Nagy can be dangerous oh
he's got three receivers to one side of
her bunch package and you get aggressive
any max protects and keeps everybody in
the Blitz and now those three guys do
something cool on the backside us and
you
oh crap we got crossed up or we got
picked or you know they they three onto
DARS own over there whatever that may be
that does scare me I guess in that
matchup but I do think the 49ers can
hang in there physically with the Bears
at the end of the day I picked a push
I'm putting $10 on the Bears give me
some gold but it's 2117 bears can we
some golf picturing the bear walking out
with his pickaxe I originally wrote down
the jimmies and knew Joe's are gonna
outplay the X's and O's because the
talent gap is too wide I've been going
to the gym but then I started looking at
it and look the Bears are seven and one
at home yeah they're three and three on
the road yeah
Mitchell Tripp iski just really does not
play that well on the road yeah they
missed the last two road games and that
was the chased annual game against the
Giants and the Lions where they really
didn't play that well now and they
relied on their defense to kind of get
everything right yeah they had the
Buffalo Bills game where they won 41 a 9
but Mitch really didn't do anything in
that guy neither have two right they
lost at the Dolphins they squeaked one
out against the Cardinals and they lost
at Green Bank the Bears are a very good
home team that still had a lot of
mistakes in that Green Bay game where
this is really looking to me like
everyone crowned the Bears this weekend
it was Chicago Bears celebration week
club dub went full national scope and
everybody loved them dancing in the
locker room
San Francisco got the big win over the
nine over the Seahawks but I really
think that both teams are gonna start
slow I think that they're both coming
off of big rushes Chicago slays Aaron
Rodgers San Francisco slay Seattle the
difference is san francisco's at home
chicago's going on the road I think it's
the Robbie Gould revenge game again and
I think the Bears win this game 1716
that's a San Francisco cover and I'm
having them put 50 dollars of my money
on the San Francisco 49ers would yet for
me it's it's I think Nick Mullens since
that Seattle game has started to protect
the ball a little bit more down I think
that
it's gonna come down to how many of the
plays can guile draw up to squeak George
Kittel or or Selleck out the back to get
them in a position to let Robbie Gould
put the points on the board
I don't think Chicago's gonna move the
ball that much on this - yeah I don't
either I think sometimes Chicago gets a
little too creative and I think San
Francisco has the d-line didn't drop
people back No - Mitch beat us because I
think the way you beat the Bears is go
beat us with Jordan Howard run him 20 to
25 I call their bluff call your bluff
Andy Reid style and I and I don't think
Chicago has enough patience to stay with
the run yeah I really do I would say
that's a legitimate flaw there's no
question and I go back to preseason when
Robert Saleh said we're gonna start off
really rough and we're gonna make a
surge at the end of the season and
that's what the Niners are doing right
now yeah they got four wins if the
Niners end this year with six wins I
would not be surprised I just think that
there are a team that's gonna be
clicking I like the way their offense is
playing I like the way their defense is
playing and I think it's close and I
think that this is a let down game for
the Bears as they just got crowned by
the national media sure wouldn't be
surprised that the Niners win this game
yeah I don't think it's crazy either I
don't
this one I'm super excited about yeah
this is the game of the day right I mean
I think it's this one or Sunday night
yeah do I get to introduce the game yes
you may
all right guys for twenty five on Sunday
the Pittsburgh Steelers on the road
visiting the New Orleans Saints spread
in this game Chris is New Orleans - six
break it down and then give us your
what's the weather it's in New Orleans
playing indoors doesn't matter I'm just
curious what it's like outside yeah
what's that two minutes when they're
leaving the bus and going in and I'm not
prepared for the indoor games look it up
now I'm gonna stop your breakdown to
tell you what the weather is for an
indoor game rivalries
all right so okay thinking of other
things down look thinking of my
guaranteed to lose here you know what's
weird is Pittsburgh really has not
played many indoor games the last few
years have they not know like they have
not played one this year last year they
played one and it was
two years ago Thanksgiving night Lily
played at the Colts they won 22:17 okay
when you're an outdoor team and then you
go play a game indoors that's you said
it last week that's a treat right it's a
tree okay Oh Ben's gonna grab the ball
and go my gosh this is this is not fair
he gets to throw the ball like this
every week I mean that's what
quarterbacks that are from like Ben
Pittsburgh right Tom Brady whatever they
go into the dome and they're like this
is not even fair just can throw it
everywhere I mean that's that's how I
used to feel I used to be like oh my
gosh this is amazing you were coming
from Florida I know and it just still
was like okay I don't worry about my
senators ass getting too swampy out here
or anything it's a nice controlled
environment to have to worry about
exactly it really is all right break it
down okay so um all right so where do
you want me to start here I guess I'll
start with New Orleans is offense versus
Pittsburgh defense New Orleans offense
hey it's not great right now I don't
know what other way to say it
they're in a little bit of struggles
ville and I'm think I say that not only
from Drew Brees standpoint I don't think
the office of lines playing as good as
it can play they're banged up as hell
exactly right I don't think Sean Payton
is necessarily on his a game right now
either and then this happens in the NFL
season they will find their second win
at some point and they'll find a new
little formula to add to their existing
formula to make things confusing once
again for defenses but right now they
are in a lull they are not playing very
good football I'll say that the
Pittsburgh Steelers defense as you know
and what I think I think the Pittsburgh
Steelers defense is pretty damn good
I think they match up pretty damn good
with the New Orleans Saints offense with
the simple fact of the course can match
up with a strength of the old line right
where we know Pittsburgh z-line can
match other than I'm afraid of Brees
deep they're not if they don't have to
worry about Brees deep they don't know
yeah right they don't really have to
worry about man-to-man issues against
the Saints there's nobody to be scared
of I know it's no speed on this there's
no speed I think it's one of the issues
with the Saints that I've seen over the
last few weeks it's really funny that
Ted Ginn was the big loss I mean you
know it's a little pieces like that
though that can make a difference just a
little exactly right and that's the
thing I'm seeing reoccurring with the
Saints on offense is like the Cowboys
showed everybody get up in there
face a little bit you don't have to play
the safety thirty yards deep down the
middle of the field he can be like
twelve yards and you can have all these
people crowding the line of scrimmage I
mean they're snaps last week with the
Panthers where you the ball and I go man
all 11 guys are like within 12 yards in
the line of scrimmage and they're not
even spread out because during the
condensed formation and there's just
nothing to back them off so I am worried
about that aspect for the Saints offense
I have a hard time think they're gonna
run the ball consistently I think they
will have a hard time finding big plays
in the pass game now they might be able
to be surgical with some of their zone
passes whatever that may be
now flip it over to the other side Pitts
Saints defense I mean it's been man it's
been six sentences of no you win four
days to submit you win but what it's
been oh that was good
it's been I it's been very impressive by
the Saints defense is what I want to say
I can't not hear it I mean I know it's
been impressive that's it it's been uh
there but the Saints just like every
good defense we talking about left go
this gets gets blue in the face but
their front four is good they don't have
to help them out a whole lot or do
anything crazy they blitz just every now
and then they can trust their front four
to handle the running game along with -
Mario Davis in the middle at times right
there secondaries doing the correct
thing always is and they're playing
smart zones they're rallying making
tackles with an occasional man-to-man in
a certain situation and they make the
quarterback have to make the throw but
that's tough this week
that's tough this week it's tough tough
huh
Pittsburgh old-line is good I mean
Pittsburgh's all white I was gonna say
that the Pittsburgh olá right I would
say with their lack of injuries might
have overtaken number one offensive line
they on a five I mean they're in that
combo right look you don't have to run
Armstead yeah hunger goes down right you
got some backup guards in there right
now they're moving Andrus peat out to
tackle yeah that's thanks I know what it
is no it's it's not what it is yeah I
think at the current state of all the
NFL right now Pittsburgh with the
bestowal are it's it's Pittsburgh or the
Colts because Dallas is a little banged
up - right so we're just gonna go right
now
yes it's Colts or Pittsburgh for the to
multiply so just because a better tackle
play yeah that would say fair point
certainly okay I know shut up I'm
getting there
so I do look at Pittsburgh's offense
though as being a tough matchup for the
Saints defense okay you know I do think
they'll be able to protect I do think
the Saints are gonna go damn like we
want to play zone but this offense has
enough and enough weapons and enough
scheme to kind of pick apart our zone if
he has time to sit back there and throw
it and then also if they want to play
man that's scary too
we know I'm putting $730 on the
Pittsburgh Steelers 730 530 Wow and I
really think they're going to win the
game and I see that Isis to get six
points I sat back and was like wait and
I'm kind of rooting for Pittsburgh right
now I want them to be in the playoff
forgot this is your Super Bowl matchup
right but I want it's very gonna be a
preview I know it'd be interesting but I
really do want them in the playoffs just
as a pure fan so I like literally pick
the game and I was like wait hold on am
I being biased here like calm down like
what's real like I truly tried to talk
myself with this one and I don't think
I'm being biased with the state of the
way each team is playing right now I
really don't so I could be wrong I don't
know but I do think Pittsburgh's playing
better football and I do think
Pittsburgh matches up better than they
are and I'm going with them
wow it's been what was your score 24 to
20 Steelers okay so I wrote this down as
I don't like my pick but I'm sticking
with it because of my score that I came
out with Saints just wrapped up a
three-game road streak you don't see
that a lot in the NFL three games so
they're back at home yeah first game at
home in a month the Saints at home man
they're a good team at home mm-hmm they
got that crowd going it starts getting
crazy and that's why I started to feel a
little bit better about it
the MVP chance or raining yeah they're
ready oh by the way to all the Saints
fans out there that
now responding to me saying them a
Holmes is the MVP by retorting we're
focused on the Superbowl
you weren't focused on the Superbowl
three weeks ago I've been saying your
team is going to go to the Super Bowl
just be okay with the fact that your
quarterback average is about 200 yards a
game one touchdown and now makes
constant mistakes
he's a mistake prone quarterback the
pick two it's insane Annie threw another
pick it's insane anyway I look at the
Steelers and I look at the Saints and
they're both the Steelers are coming off
a super emotional win super I mean they
they slayed the Patriots they got him I
also though didn't think the Steelers
played that great in the game I thought
their defense matched up really well but
also we just saw the Patriots diagnose
how to slow down the Steelers do you
think the Steelers can be patient enough
to run Jilin Samuels like that again I
hope so I don't know if they can I don't
know if they got that patient said yeah
I know I really I'm not sure I picked
the since they weren't even patient
enough last week I picked the Saints to
win this game 27 to 20 yeah and I was
like oh because I did what you did I
went I could see the Steelers win this
game so six points are crazy but there's
something I went back and looked at all
the Steelers games in a dome and a lot
of them are super underwhelming like
it's really weird like they just don't
score a lot of points I went back like
eight years they just don't score a lot
of point right so I think that the
atmosphere is gonna be crazy
I think Drew Brees in this team when I
look at that Panthers game they could
have won that game by 14 21 points I
started to see a little bit more signs
and I love the way the Saints defense is
clicking right now I don't think they're
gonna get a lot of pressure but if
there's one team that I think is gonna
make more mistakes it's gonna be the
Steelers you wrote in your notes
Sean Payton needs to go and find more
plays to take shots yeah and I think
this is the team to do it against that
good baby because I think the Steelers
we saw what happened with RT burns when
he kind of I think that Sean Payton is
gonna go in his bag and he's gonna go
let's take the big shots but I have the
Saints covering but I'm only putting 50
and now I'm definitely rooting on the
Saints interesting game I mean it really
is I you know the thing I'm gonna be
interested in more than anything is the
same
haven't played a good offense since the
Rams they really haven't played a good
often since then I mean I'm not gonna
say the Cowboys are good they have one
area that's really good so that's where
it's I'm really interested it's almost
like a litmus test
elissa witness litmus you're right
litmus yet to see where that defense
really is that's what I'm a being I'm
really intrigued to see well on Sunday
when Chris Boswell misses two field
goals how are you gonna feel I don't
know I don't know all right guys moving
on now Sunday Night Football the Kansas
City Chiefs on the road visiting the
Seattle Seahawks spread in this game is
Casey - two and a half Chris all right
so really quick just to go into your
notes on this case yeah it's very
interesting that one of his notes about
what the Chiefs face in the Chargers was
that the Chargers pretty much played the
entire time a base Seattle scheme yeah
like they played the Seattle scheme
holding very end until they switched it
up right how much of an advantage is
that for the Chiefs or do you think
maybe it's not because the Seahawks
haven't really been running just that
scheme the entire year yeah I mean that
she the the Seahawks this is what they
are they run that scheme on first and
second down and then on third down they
get really creative see Seattle and
that's one of their change ups this
years they do do different stuff on
third down situations where that's
encouraging and they're tough on third
down to figure out what they're doing
who's Blitzen who's covering what so
they can be very creative that way I
don't know if I feel any better about
Kansas City's chances against the
defense because there was no adjustment
made and again they just ran their own
they ran they run plays that I don't
think there was any difference from
really what they did against the
Jacksonville Jaguars and that scheme
which is the same scheme we're all
talking about great no I mean it's a
little misleading that score you know I
don't touch down right we've gone over
all of that right so yes again it is
about just Kansas City I kind of just
run their offense that's what they do
they're not like game planning special
plays to go oh let's screw disguising it
is it's a little annoying the fact that
we didn't see one Seattle beater last
week in the Chargers game when then I
watch the 49ers and like every time they
draw back to pass
it's a Seattle beater I want to bake did
can I play quarterback for that team I
mean holy crap I mean just throw a
wide-open guy throw another wide open
guy throat of a screen wide open I mean
it was unbelievable they don't do that
and the Seahawks defense it's it's not
the best defense in football but they're
a different unit at home
oh yeah it's again an environment that
is unlike any other when you go and play
there and I can't even imagine what it's
like at nighttime I've been a nighttime
preseason game and I thought wow this
place is crazy and preseason so they're
gonna be ready to go on the other side
of the ball this is where it's
interesting to me you know the Seahawks
still an underwhelming pass offense okay
it's still same old bull crap I've been
complaining about it's it's Russell
please say you wrote down in your
Seattle note yeah you wrote the Chiefs
should feel very comfortable playing man
against the seal I think they can just
really what they want to do yes it is
what they want to do and I think yeah
this is a game they can get away with it
where they couldn't get away with it
against the Chargers last week cuz
there's just too many mismatches along
the lines you know and the scheme is
good with the Chargers hey hey Baldwin
and Lockwood are really good don't get
me wrong they're not superstars but
they're really good sure but the old one
looked healthy health he did look
healthy healthy but I don't think
they're a superstar enough to where
Kansas City's gonna go
we can play man on them every now and
then and because the schemes now crazy
they're not gonna be worried about some
crazy play where they're gonna be
totally outmatched if they're man-to-man
it's kind of basic that way the game
comes down to you know Seattle's run
game can they be effective there Chris
Carson's a ball Chris Carson's a baller
I mean just run so hard and really the
Chiefs ability to contain Russell Wilson
a little bit because that's what it's
gonna be it's gonna be run the ball
Chiefs gonna try to put extra people in
the bog yeah it's gonna be just Wilson
hit the one-on-one shots yeah three more
on the outside and get another shot
that's really how I see the game
unveiling more than not I'm bowing $10
on the Seattle Seahawk what's your score
and I'm picking the Seattle Seahawks to
win this football 32:27 yes I know and
my heart wanted to pick the Chiefs let
it really did a 3227 game between the
Chiefs and Seahawks sounds so much fun
yeah cuz it's gonna be two quarterbacks
that really get out there and do it yeah
I think it's gonna come down to the
Seahawks running game can Kris Carson
just take them down on can they do what
Baltimore did and just pound and pound
and pound and pound and will they stay
with it we know they will because
they're obsessed with the running in
Seattle out Baltimore Kansas City and
Seattle that's what this comes down to
it really that's how I break down it
yeah I like it but I think that Patrick
mahomes having just seen the Seattle
scheme I think that coming off of a loss
I have the Chiefs winning this game 23
to 20 and I'm putting $50 on the chief
whose got shot then you put 5th 10 10
yeah I I think I picked the Chiefs cuz I
want them to win this game I know I did
as I was looking at it and I said hold
on Johnny
unrealistic this go back to reality and
it's just a tough place to play I owe
and I'll tell you what watching Michael
Dixon who's going to the Pro Bowl pin
San Francisco deep yeah like every time
I looked up there inside the five
differences Kyle had all the plays to
not just get out of the end yeah we're
gonna go 30 yards down the field in like
the first two plays exactly and I look
at Patrick mahomes it's gonna be all on
him but man it really is incredible when
you look at Patrick mahomes this season
and you think about the big games they
had at that Steelers second week of the
year
drops 42 points at Denver week for 27
points left-handed doing whatever he
needs at the Patriots what do you mean
40 points not even an issue at the Rams
51 points at home against the Ravens and
chargers wasn't really his fault they
scored 55 points in those two games I
have no fear
that mo Holmes is gonna have a dud yeah
I really don't and I don't think the
Seahawks have faced a guy like this all
year I don't think any team has like
Phillip Rivers face at the beginning of
the game when mahomes rolled out right
and threw the touchdown you wrote in
your notes was absolutely incredible and
you still don't know if he was trying to
throw to tie
we kill there or the guy that actually
caught the touchdown Johnson right but
uh I I have the utmost faith that I saw
Rogers get out of the pocket on the
Seahawks and throw some bombs right so
yeah you could certainly see it
happening it's it's just gonna come down
to do the Seahawks when they get into
the red zone
finish with touchdown sure because they
are a team that has look at the Vikings
came beautiful drives that just fall
apart at the end yeah I know they are a
team that unless they get the lock at
bomb I don't know if they finish in the
Reds are kind of yeah you're very right
I mean they're more yes yeah all right
guys last game of the week here at
Oakland on Monday Night Football spread
in this game is Denver - two and a half
Chris okay
at Oakland in the black hole Broncos
defense you know the Broncos defense is
respectable there's no denying that I
mean there's there's a lot of rings from
Shane ray and and yeah I don't know what
he thinks is disrespectful about being
told you're gonna be inactive in the
middle of the week that's completely
respectful but I guess he didn't he
believed he was better than the guys
that were playing yeah also Chris Harris
out Chris Harris at Roane IR yep so yeah
I mean Shane ray it's over in Denver
he's moving on that's just the way it is
and yeah it's been he's been
underwhelming what was he a top 12
top-10 pick right in there he fell
because of the marijuana oh that's right
he ended up in twenties right and we
went this is the reason why Denver's
amazing yeah 23:23 was it okay okay okay
so I guess I still look at you know the
Oakland offense there's just not a lot
there I mean Derek Carr is under
pressure a lot I have a hard time
thinking even with Chris Harris out I
don't really care that they're gonna be
consistently open in the pass game you
know can they run the ball will be
really the big thing in the game
altogether the Raiders have been so hit
or miss in the run game and really the
Broncos have been to a degree two teams
have been able to find little ways to
finagle run plays off of them throughout
the year if there's a creative guy on
that side of the ball that can kind of
figure out okay this is what they do
oh they do this Kyle did it to them the
week before we saw Jeremy Bates early in
the year there
a few other games too girly and the Rams
all of that but I still have a hard time
thinking that the Raiders can protect
the Raiders can run the ball
consistently I flip it over to the other
side of the ball I mean I don't think a
whole lot of this Denver offense I of
course think a lot of Phillip Lindsey
and I think it's only a matter of time
before he breaks a few plays is really
how I look at it you know the the
Raiders defense they play hard they're
pretty well coach there's just not
enough playmakers there on that side of
the ball and I think because of that I
go $10 on the Denver Broncos but I think
it's a close game I do I'm going 23 20
goes win I believe that this is the nail
in the coffin events Joseph I believe
this is part of the rallying cry of Jon
Gruden at home I think that the Derek
Carr passing game somehow gets going
without Chris Harris on the field you
know I know that Von Miller should get
two and a half three sacks just on the
tackles of this Oakland team alone right
but I believe that the Raiders get it
going and they win this game 26 to 24
and I actually bet $100 on the Oakland
Raiders oh say that's crazy
the main reason is Denver the last few
weeks has been so deflating that I look
at this offense Case Keenum is a risky
guy and he does not have the weapons to
take the risks anymore no he's not even
Dave I feel like they'd handcuff them
right so the Cleveland game for for
Vance Joseph to be down four points and
to kick a field goal with four minutes
left right he should not have been the
coach after that game you can't area
that's ridiculous
it was ridiculous they lose at San
Francisco they come back and lose at
Cleveland I think it all falls apart
here in ours apart far apart apart apart
hair it all fires up hard today
but so happy that they're keeping wit
and boog and tests back together for
another year good to have those guys
quality all right so that wraps up the
week 16 pic show I don't like when
you've let me be on that limb by myself
before we get to your lock we agreed on
eight
was a need yeah disagreed on eight so
but it really it comes down to those two
games disagreements this week Cleveland
Cincinnati Chris you're going with
Cleveland left go you have the Bengals
Buffalo New England Sims you are going
Buffalo plus thirteen left go going New
England - third awesome Green Bay at the
Jets Chris you are going Green Bay plus
two and a half left go going New York -
two and a half Giants at the Colts Chris
you have Indy - nine and a half left go
you have the Giants plus nine and a half
and then the last four games of the week
you all disagree on so Chicago has San
Francisco Chris going Chicago - four
left go San Francisco plus four that's a
bad one Pittsburgh at New Orleans Chris
going Pittsburgh plus six left go as New
Orleans - six sums taken three of the
four road teams Sunday Night Football
chris has Seattle plus two and a half
left go has Kasey - two and a half and
then Monday Night Football
chris has Denver - two and a half left
go as Oakland plus two and a half two
big bets of the week Simms has 730
bleacher bucks on the Ravens and 730
bleacher bucks on the Steelers I like
that your big money though is on teams
to cover the spread
yeah teams that are the underdogs right
because I feel like you're a lot better
at that than when you put all your money
on a team that's favored by like let's
say 11 and let go your big bed of the
week is Dallas - 7 for 250 you also have
the Dolphins - 4 for 200 which good luck
with that
I mean betting's crazy we have others
agree agree on where I'm going to
disagree now though because I have like
every $10 on and you've gone 150 on some
of the via greener I'm gonna root
against money you can make this gap up
yes week yeah you can if you go 1460 on
those two which was your SAT score if I
remember it was exactly then then you go
1460 and I lose I mean you definitely
cover some growth yeah I know we log in
this week well now that I have to think
about it damn i'm IM liking dallas - 7 i
this is the [ __ ] i can't lock
baltimore which is so annoying why can't
you lock ball because it's a Saturday I
mean you're Adam Lefko your lead host at
bleacher report who's making these rules
that comes out to Sunday morning
oh I'm gonna lock my own - for ZUP likes
I'm gonna lock Miami - for dude I have
no idea I'm not confident any all right
well in that case we got one thing left
to do that means you're good because
usually when you say that and then I'm
confident it usually means you've run
away well so many of the games I'm
confident Sims isn't confident in which
is just rough I don't know all right let
me this time we don't know the theme of
guaranteed to lose Sims
oh you're screwed that done zooms take
me to ten no see oh it's a Christmas
season and the Redskins are gonna lose
yeah I guarantee it have you seen your
quarterback it's Christmas
you're lose hey sorry Merry Christmas
Titans you get the Redskins they're not
even good on offense and their
quarterback is Josh Johnson there's a
list that's naughty or nice I checked it
once and I checked it twice so go and
get all the boys and girls and take a
trip to Gerry's world that's right
you're a buck you're on the naughty list
you're a Buccaneer you steal and have a
sword and you're missing an eye
you got an eyepatch sure are you can win
it Christmas against a bunch of cowboys
sorry Tampa you're gonna lose Merry
Christmas duh but you've gotta go
because you are from Buffalo oh and
that's right it's New England and they
don't give away Christmas gifts sorry
Buffalo the evil Lord of Belichick will
ruin the Christmas spirit
Buffalo loses that overhead it's not
Superman he's close to dead his
shoulders not working and he's on IR
right everyone knows it could produce a
scar but Atlanta is not that safe and I
don't know what you're going to pick so
why don't you say it now I'm gonna stop
trying to rhyme you're wasting time but
I was gonna pick Carolina to win the
game and then I found out Cam Newton's
out and that's a shame because now
you're gonna lose I don't know who your
backup quarterback is but you're just
gonna lose I'm sorry Carolina
you're losing to Atlanta and I can't
even believe I'm saying that out loud
and I'm guaranteeing it so for all of me
it was going west and I know these teams
I know them the best and there's one
thing that I really know for sure is
that guaranteed to lose your cure yeah
yes Arizona you're gonna lose sorry it's
Christmas and my mom mama looka boo boo
D D D Dirty Diana Sims says you're going
to lose
along with Sharon left oh and her
Hanukkah holiday giving it's a Christmas
Hanukkah disaster for the Arizona
Cardinals Juliet Phil and Bruce and that
has been guaranteed to lose well done
guys well done man I'm your rhyming is
amazing I don't know who to pick well
you know what some would say it's
lyrical lemonade you don't even know who
they are I asked you about what videos
they make I'll tell you after no I'm not
gonna know any of the songs or any of
them a single one really yeah I mean not
one group that I would know you don't do
YouTube you don't do it YouTube music
video culture you don't do it I mean
they make videos for like underwhelming
rap groups I mean what is this I don't
even get this I would say it's up and
coming up and coming okay it hasn't hit
the radio yet so when you're in the car
driving around you're not gonna do you
know any of them no but I know what this
is right I just don't know the actual
rap the one thing you'll appreciate is
the sort of alder music video starts
with a lighter being flicked yeah so
little Wayne daddy cigars let's wrap
this podcast out four sips peace out
homey forfend Rick good evening and this
is my last pics podcast of the regular
season I'm not here next week see you
guys where are you going
don't Argentina whoa so know I'll see
you guys on New Year's oh I'll see you
guys on New Year's Eve I said I will see
you in 2018 okay good
see ya 2018 Argentina thank you I
appreciate that
say hi to Lionel Messi for me I will if
I see him I will send my regards and I
will tell him that he would have no shot
to play on the American roster if we let
our football players play thank you
that's all
that's right now he can't mess a tyree
kill are you kidding me I will let him
know and for the lef koe man we will
holla at you guys I hope that these
playoff races get super spicy for week
17 it should be good well holler at you
later enjoy your weekend enjoy the games
whose
you